[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
incarcéré c'est tout ce que vous avez
l'impression de ne rien contrôler ici
c'est normal je peux très bien le
comprendre
[Musique]
papa j'ai besoin du signe ça
quand la piscine que ça vous plaise ou
non vous avez réintégré la détention
général pas tous les autres
est ce que tout le monde est prêt à
trois tués ou la porte
voilà
quel toit
si tu arrives à rester là dedans plus de
cinq secondes tu te prends avec moi car
l'odeur
le but du programme c'est d'apprendre à
dresser les chevaux sauvages
et au bout du compte notre
réhabilitation
notre objectif est de ressentir de
l'empathie c'était moi la qos et tu me
laisser tout seul
tu crois que monter à cheval ça va
changer les choses tubercule est
refermée
peuple et dépouillent les autres n'y a
rien à en tirer
[Musique]